Es ist absolut rätselhaft woher wissen elefanten dass ein tsunami kommt eines ist sicher
irgendwas wissen spüren tiere was wir überhaupt nicht mitbekommen dass sich vögel am magnetfeld der erde orientieren das ist inzwischen
wissenschaftlich bewiesen für den sogenannten sechs sinn wird jeder dagegen gibt es noch keine eindeutigen belege doch es gibt viele hinweise darauf
Dass es sich vor naturkatastrophen in sicherheit bringen wie tiere in die zukunft
Sehen was der sechste sinn der tiere wahrscheinlich ist und ob wir das verhalten der tiere eines tages als frühwarnsystem nutzen
Können jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Auch das war übrigens einen themenvorschlag von den klicks whatsapp danke dafür
Der link zu whatsapp kommt am ende des videos und ist natürlich in der video beschreibung kurz vor der jahrhundertkatastrophe
ende des jahres 2004 als ein gewaltiger tsunami, im indischen ozean und
230.000 menschen töten wird verhalten sich die tiere der gegend äußerst unruhig
elefanten
beispielsweise sie bewegen sich nervös breiten ihre ohren aus und schließlich drehen sie sich
Um und rennen einen berg hinauf auch die vögel steigen verschreckt in den himmel und fliegen landeinwärts irgendwie
Müssen sie wohl die drohende gefahr gewittert haben oder war es etwa reiner zufall doch es gibt immer wieder
medienberichten nach denen bei großen naturkatastrophen
wie eben diesen tsunami
im indischen ozean viele tiere verschont bleiben wohingegen ja hunderttausende
menschen in diesem fall sterben und ganze landschaften zerstört werden könnten also viele menschenleben vor solchen katastrophen
Gerettet werden wenn wir das verhalten der tiere beachten und es als eine art frühwarnsystem nutzen könnten
sicher ist jedenfalls tiere setzen mehrere sinne gleichzeitig ein und nehmen kleine
Veränderungen so sehr viel früher war als menschen es gibt eine studie der university of virginia als im jahr 2009
Die verschiedene erklärung für dieses frühwarnsystem der tiere hat demnach konnten
Elefanten schon sehr viel früher hören dass sich das wasser. Im indischen ozean zurück ziehe zudem sind elefanten auch in der lage
Wellenbewegungen, im untergrund zu spüren eben genau diese die auch durch erdbeben verursacht werden. Eventuell hat den auch ihr riechorgan
verraten dass das wasser vom land zurück weicht vielleicht hat ja auch schon einmal ähnliche geschichten über außergewöhnliches tierverhalten vor anderen großen
naturkatastrophen gehören china wurde nach einem erdbeben
im jahr 2008 beispielsweise von tausenden von kröten berichtet die über die straßen hüpften später starben dann mehr als 50.000 menschen
Dagegen steht die ahnungslosigkeit von seismologen die es wenige sekunden vor dem erdbeben wissen dass es so weit ist bislang kann
Man einfach nicht voraussagen wann und wo sich die spannungen an den erdplatten entladen werden zwar gibt es beispielsweise in mexiko-stadt
Effiziente warnsysteme um die menschen zu alarmieren doch das ist fast ein einzelfall weltweit die herausforderung liegt einfach darin dass
Hochsensible sensoren gut überlegt platziert werden müssen und elefanten kröten und vögel stehen nicht alleine
im fokus von forschungsteams weltweit auch bei anderen tierarten wie beispielsweise ziegen und roten
waldameisen konnten bereits hinweise auf den sechsten sinn der tiere beobachtet werden der deutsche biologe martin wikelski vom max planck institut
für ornithologie
Hat erforscht dass ziegen vor einem, ausbruch, des vulkans ätna
außergewöhnlich aktiv wurden und dass mehrere stunden bevor der vulkan tatsächlich aussprach damit sind die ziegen den menschlichen
prognosen weit voraus denn ja es gibt einige prozesse die einen vulkanausbruch
Ankündigen doch der konkrete zeitpunkt vögel aus braucht und auch seine stärke das ist viel, zu komplex
Um es im vorfeld physikalisch, zu berechnen jedenfalls für uns menschen ist es unmöglich ihn vorherzusagen und es sind nicht nur ausschließlich
säugetiere die ein solch besonderes gespür haben auch rote waldameise neben reagieren
offensichtlich auf ein anstehendes erdbeben das haben deutsche
Forschungsteams aus duisburg und dortmund entdeckt zunächst sind sie wohl durch ihre
speziellen sinnesorgane in der lage aufsteigende gase und womöglich
Auch elektrische spannungen wahrzunehmen die ameisen bauen ihre hügel. Also genau dort wo sich groß und bruchstücke der erde
gegeneinander schieben die vermutung der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler dies versorgt sie mit einer wärmeren und feuchteren
umgebung das deutsche forschungsteam hat über drei jahre hinweg beobachten können dass die ameisen sehr empfindlich auf
aktivitäten unter der erde reagierten diese warfen ihren gewohnten und sehr durchgeplanten tagesablauf
Durcheinander doch am ende ihrer studie fordert das forschungsteam zunächst noch weitere untersuchungen um zufalls beobachtungen mit aller sicherheit
ausschließen zu können teams aus
verhaltensbiologen weltweit vermuten dass vor allem das schwarmverhalten der tiere sie so intelligent macht
Das ist interessant das heißt also nicht die tatsache dass ein einziger elefant spürt dass sich etwas mit dem wasser ändert ist demnach
entscheidend stattdessen seien die gemeinsame verarbeitung dieser reize und die interaktion der tiere der schlüssel
Vergleichbar mit dem beispiel eines einzelnen fisches der im großen see als individuum verloren ist als schwarm dagegen wissen die tiere
dagegen genau
Wo sie futter oder einen sicheren platz finden also eine kollektive intelligenz quasi eine art algorithmus
im verhalten der tiere
der ihnen das überleben sichert wie genau aber
Stehen die interaktion der tiere und eher verhalten in der gruppe
Im zusammenhang mit dem sechsten sinn genau dieser frage will das so genannte ikarus projekt weiter erforschen
Im kurs steht für international cooperation for research on you sing space der plan die schwärmer der tiere beobachten
Egal wo sie sich gerade befinden und das vom schreibtisch aus dafür werden kleine
solarbetriebene gps sender mit einer antenne auf der internationalen raumstation iss verbunden
Also die sender sind auf den tieren und senden zur raumstation
wann bewegen sich die tiere wohin das bewegungsprofil von zahlreichen elefanten vögeln und ameisen könnte am ende endlich aufschluss über
Ihren sechs hingeben und sobald dieses phänomen genauer erforscht ist könnte man es möglicherweise auch schon als ein
Zuverlässiges prüfern system für uns menschen nutzen wenn er als erstes neues zum thema
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr deutlich vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von klicks zum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken hier
Also da geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken top sieben tiere auf drogen ja ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran